نانا، لقد سمعنا المزيد من التفاصيل الآن من
أوكرانيا حول انفجار جسر القرم
في أكتوبر، ما الذي يمكنك أن
تخبرنا به أكثر عن ذلك، نعم
بالتأكيد، أقصد في الوقت الذي
احتفلت فيه أوكرانيا بانفجار الجسر
ولكن لم يكن هناك اعتراف
بالمسؤولية، على الأقل لا يوجد
اعتراف واضح بذلك  المسؤولية ولكن
يبدو أن هذا هو أوضح علامة على
المسؤولية التي شهدناها منذ
ذلك الانفجار. أرسل نائب وزير الدفاع الأوكراني
برقية لإدراج
الإنجازات الرئيسية الـ 12 التي حققتها
القوات المسلحة الأوكرانية منذ
بداية الغزو الروسي
وإدراجها في تلك القائمة هو  انفجار جسر
القرم الآن بالطبع في
ذلك الوقت كانت هذه ضربة قوية لموسكو
ليس فقط من حيث
عملياتهم العسكرية في أوكرانيا ولكن بالطبع
كانت ضربة نفسية ضخمة وكان هذا
إنجازًا ضخمًا يقع من خلال
ربط شبه جزيرة القرم المحتلة روسيًا
بالطبع كان هذا
إنجازًا كبيرًا من الناحية اللوجستية، لكن بالطبع كان هذا
أيضًا نصرًا كبيرًا لأوكرانيا، لذا فإن
رؤية هذا الاعتراف الآن ربما
يكون بمثابة التعزيز المطلوب من حيث
الدعاية ربما مع استمرار أوكرانيا
في هجومها المضاد.